let's talk about why there have been so
many coups in Africa recently
[Applause]
countries in West and central Africa
have had military takeovers since 2020
and they're all former French colonies
some of these countries we've seen
things like this
big crowds protesting against France
we've had the Arab Supreme this is the
Franco Point spring people are fed up
with civilians ruling countries without
delivering beyond their own interests so
it looks like there's a pattern here but
what connections can we really make
between what's happening in these
countries and where do France and Russia
fit in
okay so these are the six countries
we're talking about Mali Burkina Faso
Chad Guinea Niger and Gabon are all now
being run by military leaders after the
Army kicked out the civilian government
Niger and Gabon are the most recent in
all of these places we've generally seen
popular support for the coup leaders
although the idea that they're all just
motivated by the public interest is a
bit simplistic in the eyes of many
observers they have conducted these
coups very much as a cynical power play
we should also add this disclaimer it's
hard to make simple comparisons that
apply neatly to all six places each
country has its own particular context
in Gabon for example the trigger for the
coup was the contested re-election of
President Ali Bongo his father had ruled
for decades before him and Bongo was
accused of rigging the vote
a lot of people celebrated what they see
as the end of The Bongo era foreign
was a democratically elected leader his
election in 2021 was the country's first
civilian to civilian transfer of power
one explanation for the coup in July is
that it was a straight up power struggle
the zoom was making changes to the
military leadership and one of his
generals after rahmanciani turned on him
when there were rumors that his job was
on the line so it's easy to find
differences between the various coups
when you look at the local context and
the specific conditions in each country
but there are also some common themes
that can help us make sense of what's
going on
first up the feeling that the civilian
governments in these countries just
weren't delivering remember these are
some of the poorest countries in the
world most of them have valuable natural
resources for example Gabon and Chad
have oil Niger and Mali have uranium
Guinea and Burkina Faso have gold and
other minerals but that wealth hasn't
been reaching Ordinary People there is a
general disenchantment with the way that
Democratic Elites have handled power the
common thread of all these schools in
West Africa and central Africa basically
are economic stagnation corruption and
insecurity that brings us to our second
theme the security problems that these
countries face it's especially bad in
Mali Burkina Faso and Niger they're all
in a region called the Sahel which has
become a stronghold for armed groups
linked to Al-Qaeda and isil and here's
the statistic that might surprise you
according to one report almost half the
deaths from terrorism around the world
in 2022 happened in the Sahel that was
more than South Asia the Middle East and
North Africa combined as the security
and humanitarian crisis has skyrocketed
in the Sahel the populations have become
increasingly impatient with the
ineptitude and failings of their own
governments in Mali Burkina Faso and
Niger the coup leaders have held up the
security situation as part of their
justification for taking power just
listen to what they said in Niger you
what's the difference it is
now our last common theme is a big one
and it's the upswell in opposition to
France and its role in the region France
is the old colonial power here so we're
talking about a relationship that's
rooted in a history of exploitation one
that goes all the way back to the slave
trade and a lot of people feel that the
exploitation hasn't stopped and instead
continues in new ways what's sometimes
called neocolonialism it's this idea
that France maintains an unequal
relationship with its former colonies in
a way that prioritizes its own political
and economic interests one example that
often comes up is how French companies
are heavily involved in mining the
natural resources of these countries for
example operating niger's uranium mines
and extracting the uranium that France
needs for its nuclear power plants now
those exports do generate revenue for
Nigeria's government France has also
been one of the biggest donors of Aid to
the region so there are different layers
to what's going on but still the
backlash against what many see as
France's outsized influence in its
former colonies is something that's come
up in several of the recent coups
because the previous civilian leaders
were often seen as being too cozy with
France the people that you saw in the
street in Niger in in Mali in Burkina
Faso
or clapping and dancing
for the cool authors was not because
they love disguise they blame their
political Elite and they blame the
colonial Master the French for not
trying to solve their problem but
exploiting their resources and while
leaving them in abject poverty
another aspect of the anti-french mood
has to do with the security threat in
the Sahel that we mentioned France has
been one of the main Western countries
to send troops to fight the armed groups
there it first sent soldiers to Mali in
2013 and had some success at the
beginning but even after several years
of French boots on the ground things
weren't really improving much its focus
has been narrowly on counter-terrorism
that doesn't deliver much benefit for
the local people
those Jihadi groups have actually become
more powerful on the ground as they've
exploited local community disputes so
the people have seen France's
intervention and then connected the dot
and said well you've intervened but
things have actually got worse people
started to see as if France was playing
um you know double sides that there are
feeding these conflicts and to try to
take benefit of it that is of course no
proof of that but a lot of people
throughout the region believe that and
this is a narrative that many of the
coup leaders have also used to their
advantage they've placed themselves
pretty firmly on the anti-french
anti-colonial side to win public support
those military factions saw which way
the wind was blowing and have used
anti-french sentiments certainly to
um bolster their own credibility the
leaders in Mali and Burkina Faso have
pushed out all French troops and the
Niger leaders had called for France to
withdraw the one and a half thousand
French soldiers there now in parallel
with that anger that we've been seeing
directed towards France there's also
something else going on and that's
growing support for Russia
after some of the coups we also saw big
crowds waving Russian Flags where you
have had France being driven up that
vacuum has been filled by Russia Russia
has a long history of quoting African
States since the Cold War
and part of its interventions even in
that era were couched in
anti-colonialists rhetoric I think
one of the main ways that Russia has
grown its influence has been through the
Wagner group private military company
with ties to the Russian government it
provides governments with soldiers often
in exchange for access to Natural
Resources the Wagner group is not just a
mercenary group it's also a Logging
Company it's also an information
communication company it's it's um it's
mining it's also serving a purpose for
these governments in the region that
seek alternative Partnerships to the
West Wagner has been active in several
African countries including Mali since
2021. the coup leaders there brought in
Wagner mercenaries to help fight against
the armed groups in the Sahel and
there's been talk about the military
leaders in Burkina Faso and Niger
bringing Wagner forces too although so
far there's been no confirmation of that
future of the Wagner group in Africa
just became a lot harder to predict
since Wagner's leader Evgeni pagosian
was killed in a plane crash in Russia a
lot of people suspect President Putin
may have orchestrated that crash to take
revenge for a mutiny that pagosian led
against the Russian state in June the
Kremlin has denied playing any role in
his death I'm not quite sure that by
removing pregasing Wagner's Machinery is
just sort of suddenly going to
disintegrate whether it's still called
Wagner whether it will be the same
network of individuals now being
supervised with close to our allies more
accountable to Putin they will want to
keep that Machinery that Wagner has
built on the ground because it's
achieved a number of objectives for them
access to Resource undermining The
credibility of the West so when you look
at the forces that play with all these
coups in Western central Africa there's
a lot going on you've got the domestic
issues in each country you've got
Regional issues like the security
challenges in the Sahel then there are
these bigger geopolitical forces too the
pushback against France and Russia's own
Ambitions to grow its influence it's all
adding up to this sense that coups are
in the air and the big question is
whether more countries will follow